our shoutout tonight for a reporter who
has his own investigative fund and has
been working with the Georgia Coalition
for the people's agenda to produce a
powerful lawsuit and some powerful
stories Palace investigation really took
off when he discovered that this elderly
woman Christine Jordan was turned away
from voting on election day in Atlanta
her name purged from the voting rolls in
Georgia supposedly because she had moved
how long you've been voting miss Jordan
was not just anyone
she's the 92 year old cousin of Martin
Luther King jr. she was thrown with
polling station because they said she
had moved she's been the same house for
over 50 years and she was the host of
Martin Luther King after he would give
his sermons at the Ebenezer Baptist
Church he hasn't moved anywhere but they
threw her out for moving miss Jordans
granddaughter told Palace no one could
explain how her name was taken off the
eligible voter list being able to vote
and no one can give you an explanation
and it bothers me it bothers me to my
core like there's actually no record of
her whatsoever voting in any election
whatsoever it's ridiculous
panelist discovered what was going on at
the Secretary of State's office in the
Georgia capitol and elsewhere for six
years I've been hunting down these
secretaries of state the people in
charge of our voter rolls who've been
playing games by removing voters of
color from the voter rolls in Georgia it
was Secretary of State Brian Kemp who
was running for governor of the state
I'm Brian Kim if you want a politically
incorrect conservative
that's me I demanded that he give me all
the information on the people had been
removing from the voter rolls the names
addresses
he said hundreds of thousands of people
almost half a million had moved out of
Georgia in two years and then he
confronted him about what was going on
why do we have to sue you to get them to
get the names of voters who've been
removed so I when he stonewalled me on
his list of people he removed I did
something that it's rarely done I
actually filed a federal lawsuit under
the National Voter Registration Act
which said you have to hand over your
files because it's about manipulating
the voter rolls a judge ordered Brian
Kemp to turn open up his files on the
voter seeds removed how he removes all
backed by the Palas investigative fund
we have an expert team that that it was
that's pretty hard to match anywhere
it's very expensive very difficult what
I've been able to accomplish with this
lawsuit is not only opening up the files
of these officials who are secretly
playing games of the voter rolls I'm
opening up for every investigative
reporter and reporting team I've gotten
calls from many many papers and many
outlets for this information voter fraud
is all too common President Trump made
much of alleged voter fraud in this
country people voting twice when he
appointed the Secretary of State from
Kansas Kris Kobach to head up a special
investigative Commission which has yet
to turn up any evidence of widespread
voting fraud we want to make America
great again we have to protect the
integrity of the vote and our voters
when Trump said that there's massive
vote rigging I think he's right but it's
the cronies behind him who've been the
center of the vote rigging and palaces
that Kansas secretary of state is one of
the culprits sending other states
cross-check lists of common names
alleging they have registered twice mr.
kobak hey hey I want to congratulate you
you are the number one fraudulent voter
hunter in the United States you're the
guy behind the cross-check list the
title on this list is duplicate voters
okay so wait I've noticed you know most
of the names you've said that there are
as a massive problem with double voters
you've given out this list please sir
and this is daughters this is the list
you say it's potential double voters
fella says he hopes all the reporters in
the US will pick up now on what he has
been doing it's not my job to elect or
stop a theft of election or do anything
you know that's not my job my job is to
expose this material this is part of a
national program to remove voters of
color before the 2020 election now this
isn't about Democrats or Republicans
it's about right and wrong it's about
whether we're gonna use a kind of new
Jim Crow trickery to remove voters of
color and young people from the voter
rolls well I got to tell you that being
an investigative reporter is a lot
better than working for a living that's
our program for tonight thanks for
joining us we'll see you back here next
week